so I found myself in New Zealand six and
a half thousand feet up a mountain in a
lycra suit with the crew not knowing why
the hell I was there and beat attacks
and laughing at me I actually went to
Lancaster University to study visual
arts I was a passionate as growing up as
a passionate artists and graphic
designer and that's what I wanted to do
and i went to lancaster university
because it happened to be near the lake
district because I was a big climber as
well so that was a big draw for me but
when I arrived at Lancaster I didn't
actually realize I hadn't done the
research and I realized that you had to
do another subject in your first year
and I really didn't have a clue what I
wanted to do I just wanted to paint and
sculpt and make things and so and there
happened to be I mean there all manner
of choices but I I really wasn't certain
what to do and they were they have to be
a really great theater Studies
department so in my first year I started
I I did I took theater studies and I
started to make make things for sets
built design sets and make props and
design posters for shows and then
gradually during the first year I
started I got involved in productions
and I started to act playing small roles
the end of the first year I played the
lead role in a play by Barry Keith
called gotcha
and I happened to work with a student
director who was very much into
Stanislavski and we went through this
whole kind of method of the met you know
kind of stanislavski's method to build a
character and I did this play and
literally at the end of doing that play
I went I'm not gonna be an artist I'm
gonna be an actor phoned up my parents
told him I wanted to become an actor
great big silence at the end of the
phone it was bad enough they wanted you
know me being an artist but I mean being
an actor was about as bad as he got and
and you know and and and that was and
that was it so from then I changed my
degree and you could build your own
degree there at Lancaster using a sort
of a module system and I went about
creating an independent Studies degree
in I think I called it theatre design
and movement and and and just basically
built my own courses and studied the
movement sort of all sorts of dance as I
was following and studying and
theatre practitioners brushed
Stanislavski all of these things sort of
building up a knowledge one thing you
said they're particularly struck me the
fact that quite apart from the visual
arts that originally true you took
Lancaster and then your interest in
interacting movement and dance were a
fairly early enthusiasm of yours yeah I
mean I suppose the combination of
character and it was sort of character
based movement you know movement it was
was of great interest to me and
obviously that was going to play a part
later on although at the time I really
didn't know how or why having got your
Equity card you joined I understand it
was a series of touring companies and
and you got into if I've got it right
acting some of the you know some of the
big Shakespearean roles
what's of influence did that have on you
yeah actually the first job that I had
was this local theatre called the Jukes
Playhouse in Lancaster and I did 14
plays back-to-back rehearsing during the
day and performing at night you know you
know in a true old fashioned rep system
and it was a great great rocker theater
education which he was very hard to have
that kind of education anymore but was
was but the great thing about it was
that the director who ran the theater
man called Jonathan pithre bridge was an
extraordinary man who had a real vision
for the theater and its place in the
community he really truly believed that
that art was art theater was was was was
there to change society and and that the
job of the actor was to go and research
find information bring it back share it
with an audience in the you know in a in
a way that would you know it was quite a
sort of political with a small P that
that has always defined my attitude
towards acting in a way that it is a
service that it's something that is for
the benefit of others before you know
you come back literally sharing your
evidence with with an audience the work
that you do
that's that I I'm really grateful for
that I work with with with someone with
that vision one of the Shakespearean
roles that I understand you did was was
the fool in King Lear which on the face
of it sounds like the perfect
introduction to the kind of thing that
you do a very physical role in a play
full of meaning absolutely that was in
fact so uh so after the Jukes Playhouse
I'd I did went onto it with a number of
different theatre companies and I found
myself in London which is where I
actually played the fool in King Lear I
also and that was with a director called
Mac Stafford Clarke and and I did
another play with him which is perhaps
more appropriate for the sort of work I
suppose that I would end up doing I mean
if the fool was a very physical
character but this other play I did
where the Royal Court Theatre was called
hush by a woman called April DeAngelis
and I played a character called dog boy
in that in that play and dog boy was a
young homeless youth who who had mental
issues and he had a dog and in during
the course of the play he kills his dog
and he becomes his dog he kills it and
he breaks into this middle-class
household and and the play is about
their choices in reaction to this event
so how they all dealt with this with
this homeless issue and I was stark
naked and and in and that was one of the
first places my dad came see he was his
premonition of me becoming an actor had
borne fruit just what I loved about
acting and loved and and what I was
learning to discover was was the the art
of transformation really that the
liberation of being able to say
something about the human condition by
putting yourself under the microscope
but actually the characters that that
that have enabled me to do that the most
I think have been ones that have been
much much further away from myself so
you're always putting that part of you
under scrutiny or you know if there's a
Venn diagram it's kind of where it
crosses over between you but the further
away that the character was from me
it seemed the more I was able to find a
sort of artistic truth if that makes
sense
dude did you find it liberating that
idea of being non-human very much so but
yeah yeah absolutely you know you're
leading the audience through a journey
you through a journey and it allows the
audience to experience the human
condition through a different prism and
that's that I find and always have done
fascinating before we get on to the way
that particular
art developed I'd like to talk a little
bit about the television work that I
mean you've done a lot of television
work over the years but the earlier
television work where you were playing
characters like like Einstein and and
Bill Sikes tell us a little about how
how that came about
what impact that had on your development
of your your your art yeah I mean I've
always really enjoyed the deep level of
kind of research into characters so so I
really the things that made me that I
concentrated on was what made me feel
most alive in my life I think witnessing
the birth the literally what witnessing
the birth of my children that were all
born at home in my house was about the
most beautiful thing I've ever seen in
my life
so so when I'm playing someone who's
taking life I can I'm able to use that
as a substitute for that so your subsidy
you you are not substituting things that
you that you go through emotionally to
create I mean that's the basis of acting
you you you are you're you're tricking
your mind in your body by by bus by
using your own personal experience to
connect with something that isn't you of
course in some ways you you push that to
the extreme once you get into the area
of performance capture and and becoming
creatures that do not even exist can you
tell us how you got into performance
capture in the first place well I got a
call from from a show I was actually
playing Bill Sikes at the time we were
shooting in Prague and
and I got a call from my then agent
saying look they're making this film of
Lord of the Rings down in New Zealand
and they want someone to do the voice
for a digital character in the Rings and
and I said well look the Rings has got
you know a dozen really good parts in it
can you don't get me up for something
decent I don't really I'm not a voice
action and I don't really want to do a
voice for a digital character so can you
just see what and so so that so then
they said well it's we're not quite sure
what it is exactly but they but but it's
it's Gollum and it's and I was going oh
right I remember Gollum from The Hobbit
I read The Hobbit I hadn't read Lord of
the Rings at the time and they said
we're not quite sure why it works but
you've got a warrant for it so I thought
well how am I gonna get audition I'm not
a voice I really am NOT just I'm not
some one of those actors who's or like a
miracle can go in and or do voices or
impressions or you know that's not me I
have to go into the character to find a
voice as part of building a character
and so I started to think about how I
could approach this and I was at home
and reading I started reading Lord of
the Rings and he was gonna be
auditioning and thinking how am I gonna
have am I gonna do this so anyway so I
started reading and you know Gollum
Gollum is you know obviously the power
of the Ring gulfs this this being and
and twists and and and contorts him and
he's called Golan because of the way he
sounds and he says he says Gollum Gollum
you know and I'm thinking how am I gonna
I can approach this you know where where
does this character carry his guilt and
pain where does it and and it was his
float I so ok let's think
okay so mania throats really constricted
okay well maybe maybe that what did what
is the ring well the rings of a bit like
an obsession is maybe he's like a made
it's like an addiction it's and he's
maybe he's like an addict you know so I
started to think about along the terms
of him being like like a heroin addict
or someone who is obsessed by something
unless they get it they're gonna go
crazy so and then I first think about
how physically how am I gonna
find this and I wanted to find something
that the effect of the ring had an
involuntary action on made him spasm in
some way and and then this is gospel
truth my cat came into the room and it
is his name's D is no longer with us and
came in and started coughing up fur
balls and he was coughing up fur balls
the whole of his head through to the tip
of his tail was doing this kind of this
kind of weird action and he started
going like that so that then became sort
of sort of you know and that was that
was sort of the genesis of of that voice
so I went in for the audition
and and I jumped up all the fur ball
player thinking and jumped up on the
chair and sort of started doing a
version of which wasn't the actual it
was a version of of that for that for
the casting director John Hubbard who
sat there and he was reading off lines
and he just went oh no he thinks this is
terrible I think this is a complete
disaster a lot really screwed this one
up and anyway so that then we've got
sent off to Peter Jackson and it came
wanted to actually meet me so I met with
them at the American Church in London
and as soon as I laid eyes on Peter
Jackson and his wife Fran Walsh I sort
of fell in love with them I literally
fell in love with him when I first met
him and he said no look we are we don't
he explained the process I he said I
want an actor to play Gollum but we
can't finally manifest him on screen
with an actor because you could never
cast someone who's three and a half foot
tall and that wiry and skinny and
emaciated and twisted and with a
slightly larger head we'd never find an
actor to do that so we're using we're
gonna animate him finally or he'll be
manifested using CG finally but we want
an actor to play him because we don't
want the actors playing Sam and Frodo to
have to imagine what what's going on
inside this guy's head you know by
looking at a tennis ball on a stick so
because at that time that's how visual
effects were created and and so so so so
I said well look I'd love to die do of
this challenge and he said yeah we're
we're toying with this idea of using
this technology which is coming out of
the medical industry called motion
capture it went from sort of thinking I
was just going to be doing this voice to
actually being down in New Zealand for a
year and a half onset work you know you
know I turned up I did some lots of lots
more sort of physical research worked
out how Gollum would move and and and
think and feel and be and behave and my
first shot in Lord of the Rings was you
know obviously it was three films but
they will shot concurrently and my first
shot was scene 729 which was half way up
Mount Doom you know trying to stop Frodo
and Sam getting to the top and so I so I
found myself in New Zealand six and a
half thousand feet up a mountain in a
lycra suit with the crew not knowing
where the hell I was there and beat
attacks and laughing at me and and so
and we did this scene and then and then
when he saw what I was doing he said
okay okay we're gonna sort of
reconfigure this we're not gonna just
animate the character and we're gonna
have a we're gonna literally copy every
single movement that Andy does and we're
gonna copy every single facial
expression that he's doing and he's
gonna become the template for this
digital character so this this began
this you know that this went on and on
you know throughout the course of Lord
of the Rings it got refined and changed
and all this technology was evolving as
we were shooting and when we came to the
end of the The Return of the King Peter
Jackson invited me over to lunch it
happened to be my birthday and he gave
me he gave me one of the original rings
from the Lord of the Rings that said
this is for you and would you like to
play King Kong
I don't think you've what and he said
yeah we're that's the next thing we're
doing and we'd like to play King Kong
and I was like so this this was the
moment really that was this the second
epiphany of my life other than you're
gonna become an actor which was I've
just been playing this three and a half
foot ring junkie and now I'm gonna play
a 25 foot gorilla this surely is the end
of typecasting as we know it this is
brilliant this is amazing this is a tool
which enables the actor to become
anything you want to be it's like mr.
Ben you go into the you know you go into
the shop and you dress up and you can
become anything you know so I said yes
of course
and then the journey of King Kong
started which was the next phase of my
life in New Zealand I spent all in all I
spent years and years and years down in
New Zealand making films is with my
great friends Peter Jackson and Fran
Walsh and Philippa boyens I mean it's
such an amazing experience so I then
found myself up in Rwanda researching
mountain gorillas and London Zoo
researching researching gorillas in
captivity and and and finding out who
King Kong was and and you know trying to
find it you know the journey for King
Kong was was in the original 1933
version Kong was a very much a monster
he was very much sort of an image of
what people thought gorillas were at the
time which were because there hadn't
been many spot you know spotted or
they're always seen through through
through through the trees as these
mysterious creatures who who were who
were violent sort of chest-thumping
creatures and there hadn't been you know
70 years of Discovery Channel or Dian
Fossey or any of that you know none of
that had happened so there was no
understanding people were afraid of
gorillas which is why he was portrayed
as a monster I wanted to make him having
been on that journey very much a gorilla
a silverback gorilla
[Music]
[Music]